homeys what is good left go here and
this episode of the left go show is
brought to you by the Walmart fan shop
the ultimate source for all sports fans
you can shop officially-licensed sports
merchandise from all 32 NFL teams and
we're talking majestic we're talking
fanatics we're talking Nike doesn't
matter your budget they got it visit the
fan shop at walmart.com slash bleacher
report oh let's go it's left go with the
Brian West book around yo I just watched
Brian Westbrook watch ditch the playbook
with Quinn and Williams yeah he is such
a freaking jet hilarious hilarious and
doesn't he he's one of these guys you
ever see a guy that doesn't even know
how funny he is a thousand perhaps what
he is he doesn't even realize it who
realize that's a great point there are a
lot of people that like heat that's the
thing is he's so purely innocent yeah at
the end of that it didn't make the final
cut I made him make a promise that to
never lose that charm because who else
has that man there's some guys that are
just so naturally funny like comedians
they have to try to be funny yes there's
other people that are just naturally
funny they just do funny stuff way they
say words you're funny like if you
haven't seen it yet ditch the playbook
with Quinn Williams the way he says oh I
need my glasses I need my glasses like
that is so funny why I got my part yes
in its and he says dope all that they
own that's dope oh that's it's a guy
from down south I mean I could tell you
sir I don't know exactly where he's from
yeah but one of my best friends Carell
buck halter you know oh my he's from
Mississippi one of the funniest dudes I
know it's just the way that they talk it
used to bring his boys up to Philly and
we used to just go back and forth one of
his friends in fact I had a pool party
at my house I'll never forget this day
he jumps in the pool with his phone in
his pocket back in the day when they
have the phones so I I mean I was doing
whatever next thing I know I hear
popping in my microwave and I couldn't
did I get you like what's going on he's
I put my phone in the microwave to dry
it out turn the microwave on Mike I had
to get a brand new microwave
I mean I'm almost killed this man and he
Larry he was dead serious no he was
serious
he thought the phone in the microwave
was gonna dry it out Wow
Crona realtor did know his boy did that
yeah it was Mississippi boys man Quinn
Williams is from Birmingham Alabama okay
yeah there's a there's like an innocence
to southern game yeah the fun it's not
about jokes it's just about having fun
yeah I love that I love that too yes so
if you haven't seen the episode check it
out we're gonna have a good conversation
a lot of runningback discussions today
yes which as we've seen with your Dalvin
cook clip that everyone people [ __ ] with
your takes on running backs
apparently they believe that you
understand the position well Dalvin cook
is getting it done it's not hard to see
anybody could see that he's getting it
done but he's quick he's fast he's
getting it done and I wish they would
use them a little bit more in the pass
game if he does that then he's taking
the next step I want to clear up one
thing a little news and notes from last
week this is just something you said
I'll take it I'll take prematurely I I
wanted that's not what I wanted so you
owe me a dollar
Oh your blood funnier thing is is that I
love the comment section a lot of people
don't like the comment section that's
where I see what people react you see
otic feel a lot of people were putting
down the quote you owe me a-- money yes
you said apparently it's some money yeah
money
Oh money means one buck you owe me a
money just one well that wasn't a [ __ ]
that was not really that was a slip okay
good
can you name for me the eight undefeated
teams in the NFL right now me and any
bird we're doing it earlier this is the
most undefeated teams entering week four
since 1998 I probably can so Green Bay
yep don't cheat I'm gonna cheat
anoche New England yep Casey yep Detroit
yep
I want to say not Indy I know that um
Dallas yep Seattle no no see how to just
lost okay um Boston on three how many is
it five I don't remember who you're
missing did you say the bills
I did not say bills and I have no clue
what's up I have no clue teams the NFC
West NFC West San Fran yep see how to
just lost so it has to be Arizona's out
who's the other team the render Rams
yeah Wow isn't that wild that is kind of
well is it surprised
I think wouldn't the most fun things
about sports is when you do like lists
and stuff yeah and you're like give me
the three top rushers in the NFL and you
just wrack your brain is this too hard
it's hard to do that though how many of
those teams here's the official list
right here yeah how many of those teams
do you believe in right now I believe in
the Chiefs I believe in the Packers the
Rams cowboys and Patriots okay so you're
not lying yet Bill's lions and Niners
right what's really interesting for me
is and we're gonna get into the games
more but two of the undefeated teeth
there's four undefeated teams facing
each other and then bills face the
Patriots this weekend and the Lions face
the Chiefs and I think I think that both
of those three-and-oh teams that people
aren't buying because I would agree I
think that the nation agrees with you
that it's a little too early to buy in
fully on the Lions and bills course but
I think that both teams are really gonna
surprise the nation with how close they
keep it this week well I'll tell you
what especially this weekend in
particularly talking about Buffalo daily
I'm the patriot you have their host an
Avenger both teams are about seven point
dogs at home which means Vegas hasn't
buying into it well buffalo has a
awesome defense you add that to the
crowd situation playing at home that
that changes that changes things you
also and I got some stats on that you
should look at what's going on with Tom
Brady playing Buffalo to different
places for different game for him yes he
throws some pics he makes some mistakes
too he never makes Tom Brady Brearley
make some mistakes he makes some
mistakes against Buffalo that you never
see against than any other team in BER
Engrish mayor and he'll was
Brady the winningest coach in rout
winningest quarterback in Ralph Wilson
Stadium history is that what it is a new
era stadium that Brady apparently has
more wins at Buffalo stadium than any
Buffalo quarterback in like the last
three decades which is insane but my big
reason I think they're both teams could
keep it close is because I respect the
defensive coaches that are ahead of
Detroit and Buffalo right mapa Tricia
and Shawn McDermott have done a great
job whenever they face look the Patriots
went into Detroit and Matt Patricia held
that offense and and everybody was going
Wow what's wrong with Tom Brady in this
offense er I look at it like this I
think Shawn McDermott has shown that he
can game plan really well for the
Patriots and he knows what they're
trying to do and I said on Monday their
offensive coordinator has Patriots ties
so much about being a good defensive
coaches knowing what the other team
wants to do is right and taking it away
that's right the other thing is is what
that what Belichick did against Patrick
mahomes and the Chiefs in the AFC
Championship game was we're gonna play
man-to-man across the field and then
we're gonna double-team Tyree kill with
Devin McCourty no matter where he goes
and it was a little bit of a cover zero
and and no one's really tried that
before no and Patricia is somebody that
is gonna watch that and is smart enough
now I get a little bit worried about the
Lions because I don't know what's up
with Mike Daniels and Darius slay might
not play and when you're missing guys to
maybe do a man-to-man concept against
the Chiefs
it scares me a lot but I have faith in
Patricia and McDermott in terms of game
planning to make to make it very
complicated for those teams I think that
I think you're right the one question
you would have you know I love the
defense if the defense is gonna do their
thing well offensively I think that at
some point the Patriots bigger they'll
figure something out
to score some points offensively will
the bills figure it out because the
Patriots defense in three weeks is in a
historic but you gotta you gotta put
that in context Jess Berg Miami the Jets
three teams absolutely just with Luke
Falk 100% right but I think that is the
question the thing is though
I look at Detroit against Kansas City
yeah I think that is a defense that Matt
Stafford III think if you really look at
their first half against Arizona in the
crunch times against Philadelphia when
they needed that touchdown to Marvin
Jones they were able to make it happen
they get a little bit too conservative
but I think the troit can put up some
points against the Chiefs and the bills
against the Patriots no struggle no
struggle to put a point III think that
you're right but I also think that Josh
Allen is the type of quarterback to kind
of make life interesting for the
Patriots where the Patriots are gonna
have to maybe spy him a little bit I
also think that Josh Allen could make a
mistake you know absolutely make some
mistakes that the big question is is
John Brown and Cole Beasley good enough
to go against man-to-man against the
Patriots right without getting the
quarterback killed I do not think so
that's the question because the run game
but the run game is okay Frank and
Singletary they're okay but they'll
figure a way to slow that down because
you're gonna play man-to-man outside you
got eight men in the bus can can those
receivers get open and can and can't you
get him in a ball that's the question so
Philadelphia fans know this very well
their weird relationship with Sean
McDermott yeah and I have been an
enormous Sean McDermott fan for a long
time I love what the bills are doing
right now from their GM mr. bean that
they stole from Carolina they pretty
much stole the two smartest people that
were all the Panthers from that 15 and
one team well that's what the John
McDermott their defensive coordinator
and their GM who was an assistant GM
under Gettleman who's now with the
Giants and they went out this offseason
they signed like five veteran offensive
linemen and it's shown to work they've
built their defense they got a Toliver
with the ninth pick which was such a
steal the way they built the secondary I
love what they're doing but Philadelphia
fans have a weird relationship
Sean McDermott was the heir apparent to
Jim Johnson r.i.p the greatest offensive
coordinator that Philadelphia has ever
seen he used to duck they just called
him the mad scientist and then Shawn
McDermott was the guy that replaced
Jim Jim Johnson right away and that
first year that defense was the worst
defense in the NFL Philadelphia fans
ranch
McDormand out of town he goes to
Carolina he builds that defense into a
great defense with Luke and and Thomas
Davis any good pieces and now he goes to
Buffalo and it keeps going and I'm
curious I want Shawn McDermott stories
out of you was there anything that comes
to mind where there's this young Shawn
McDermott guy did you guys crossover at
all or when he was coming up you were
already going no when I was coming up he
was coming up almost at the same time so
I watched him from being an intern
almost to a a grad assistant type of
position to to the point where he was a
secondary coach and then right right
before I left they were thinking about
promoting up to defensive coordinator on
a gym situation that went down so
Shawn's good to like good character he
understands the values because he went
through the system because he we started
at the bottom and worked his way up he
understands the hard work this is Linda
that the long night that's the type of
person he's a quality dude so he's not
gonna throw you underneath the bus he
got those good qualities detail-oriented
from from Andy Reid but he also knows
how to get the best out of players and
you also got that firing firing this
from Jim Johnson cuz Jim would get after
you and he had no problem getting after
you Shawn's not a guy he's not gonna
cuss him flush he's not gonna do that
but he will get after you wouldn't yes I
believe when Shawn McDermott first got
there he put like a wrestling mat in the
middle the locker room and he pretty
much was like I'll wrestle any let's go
let's go there ever a game or a moment
where you looked at Shawn McDermott and
you went oh this guy has head coach
material maybe no okay there wasn't and
at the time he was still young I didn't
think that John Harbaugh would ever be a
head coach yeah I thought that when he
got a job I didn't think he would be a
good head coach obviously I was wrong so
I'm probably not a very good judge of
that
this is this is the truth I know that
he's a hard worker which it takes to be
a coach I know he's detail-oriented the
biggest thing for coaches can you get
fifty three guys or however many guys on
the team can you get the best out of
those guys every single time they enter
the field and I can't sit here and say
that that roster has a bunch of good
guys a bunch of good great a players
some of the best in the league however I
know that Shawn has gotten the best out
of those guys the buff I know bill
I believe have the most B+ players in
the league right now all of their
offensive linemen like you look at their
offensive line you got guys like taina
Seki like this is a guy that was on
Washington for a few years and every
year they heard a starter and he was
there and now he's there I look at their
defensive line and they just lost
Harrison Phillips but their linebackers
like a Matt Milano is a guy that he's
not gonna get any attention he's
probably not gonna go their Pro Bowler
but every time I watch him he's taken
down a sake one on first contact a lot
of great I look at their safeties and
Micah Hyde everywhere but he's never
gonna be there just a bunch of B+
players which is great for a team that's
gonna go like nine and seven and punch
you in the [ __ ] mouth every week you
talk about him being a good guy that
puts in the work we do this a lot with
coaches where we make it seem like they
all put in the work no how many coaches
are put in as much work as Sean
McDermott how many coaches are not
because we never hear about the guys
that are not well I mean I think you
have to understand there are some teams
that look like they're undisciplined
that aren't doing things and that means
to me if you're if you go out there you
commit 18 penalties and penalties are
you're just penalty ridden the entire
game first three games we've seen some
teams like that Cleveland in particular
yeah that means somewhere along the line
your message either you're not doing the
work or your message is not going from
the head coach down to the player
because what we do as fans is we go man
this offensive lineman can't stop
[ __ ] Falls starting or or they're not
tackling while this is a player thing
you think when you have math issues like
that it definitely goes to the coach
absolutely that's so funny because I
always thought we blame the coaches but
really it's the players that are the
ones making those yeah but if it's one
guy that jumps off every now and then
okay that's just part of the game but if
you have 18 penalties like the Browns
had the first game oh well maybe we're
not practicing up to standard maybe
we're not putting our players in the
best position maybe I'm having guys
think too much and they're not thinking
about but they're not just going out
there reacting being athletes they're
just thinking about other things I mean
there's a lot of different ways to look
at it but at the end of the day it's the
head coach's job to make sure that you
have your best athletes in the best
position where they're comfortable so
they can go out there and perform you
don't not all coaches do that you don't
need to give me a name
if you want to I'd appreciate it but
have you ever been around a coach that
was really not putting in the time and
that it got to a point where it angered
a lot of the players
I've been around a coach that I think he
probably should have put in more time
and I also think that and I'll say this
Mike Singletary and I think he's a I was
gonna say his name no no I'm not gonna
talk about about my because I think this
I think he was a great motivator I think
that he knows a game like nobody's
business I think that is really really
hard and I'll use Michael Jordan I'll
use Mike Singletary for elite athletes
to ever show someone that's not elite
how did how to do something because the
he can he has the ability to do things
with his body with his mind he sees
things differently to me that I would
never be able to see so like when Ed
Reid went to the Buffalo Bills coaching
staff how is Edie Reed gonna explain to
a safety UK's vision and his instinct
because it either got it or you don't
well yeah I could say hey I look at the
tight in and when he does this I do this
but there's times in games where my body
just reacts if I'm talking to a running
back I say you know what this is what
you're looking at you're looking at the
defensive end if you see somebody
outside of him that you cut inside but
went in then when I'm in the game I'm
not saying okay to left step right step
and then cut I'm saying
what do you feel what do you what does
your body feel this comes from years of
experience the quality guys a good guys
at elite guys if Mike Singletary was one
of those guys it's hard to explain that
the other thing I thought about Mike was
that you know you got to put in the time
you got to understand offense and
defense you got to be able to talk to
both sides of the field and I don't know
that he had the understanding to me I
don't know that he was ready to be a
head coach because it's much more than
X's and O's it's about it's about film
study it's about preparing your team
it's about what are you doing in the
weight room where are you staying that
when you travel how do you travel it's
all those little small things what do
you eat nutrition all those small things
that head coach had to be a part also
said before his messages got stale yeah
and and the thing is is I don't think
people realize just because you're a
professional athlete we're not counting
on the millions of dollars to be your
motivator we're not counting on the wins
and losses even though they're adults
and they make
a lot of money and there no like you
still need to be motivated that's right
I think that surprises a lot of people
some people do know there's others that
are self motivate just like the real
world right there's those that go Gary
Fitzgerald we've seen everything could
be crap around him he's gonna go do it
he's gonna go no matter what because
those people those are special but I
think that the public thinks that those
people are normal
no and I'm telling you that the Larry
Fitzgerald's and the Tom Brady's and the
JJ Watts there are the freaks did their
to stop thinking that's normal but just
imagine look all the burnouts that our
first rounders they just they didn't
they weren't good enough they didn't put
enough work in they could have done a
little bit better there's a bunch of
guys that I play with that our first
rounders had a bunch of talent they
didn't want to put their work in because
there was first rounders and so they
never actually achieved their there to
their potential their level of potential
because they don't want to put the work
in now you have a bunch of guys that are
third fourth fifth rounders that put in
more work than God allows and they
actually went on to have great careers
because they put the dog won't work in
how much did being a third-round pick
help you I think for guys like me having
a chip on your shoulder
yeah being a third round pick when you
thought she should have been the first
rounder being a fourth round pick me you
thought should have been the second
rounder
that's a better motivator than anything
else is there better than money better
than girls better than whatever else
that's the best motivator because it's
about me put in the work and in every
time you step on the field I want to
beat you I'll never forget my rookie
year I got drafted to a team that had
Brian Mitchell Carell berkhalter and
Zeus daily there right and so in the
offseason after the first minicamp they
went Dorsey Levens became a free agent
and they picked up Dorsey Levens yep I'm
like so obviously that bust me down
either further you know it ended up that
career buck cause he got hurting Dorsey
was on my good friends just so I'm the
other day but now when I'm training all
off sees all my trainer was saying and
they winter they went out and got Dorsey
Levens to replace you and that makes you
work a little bit harder and there's
some guys that don't feel that some guys
they're oblivious to that type of
motivation and I think coaches are the
same way Charlotte's not like that he's
like listen I'm gonna work hard whether
I'm the coach of the little league team
or whether I'm a coach about the
professional team that's the type of
worker he is and
you watch his team that speaks volumes
about the coach yeah that's what happens
that that what you see on the field if
that doesn't it what you see on the
field doesn't represent with the coach
you saying there's something wrong with
the message it's getting lost somewhere
as someone that came in and was drafted
lower than they thought they should have
been and you have that chip on your
shoulder yeah
is it hard to not resent every
first-round pick that comes in after you
know I never resented anyone okay I've
only looked at it like well I'm gonna
beat you I'm gonna be better than you
I'm gonna I'm gonna outwork you I'm
gonna I'm gonna be in the weight room
where I'm gonna get here a little bit
earlier it was funny because you hear it
all the time he's the first one in the
last one out well there are some guys
that say you know what I take pride in
getting here early Andy Reid he would
never leave this seemed like he would be
there I would get there every now and
then 3:30 4 o'clock and Andy was already
there he would just he would just stay
there because he'd go in the morning in
the morning yeah because Andy wanted to
he didn't want to go into a game and say
you know what if I would have put in
another hour of film study I would have
probably understood what the defense was
gonna do anything for Shaun Shaun is
that he's keys cut from the same as that
cloth and that's why his team's which
again III look at the talent I'm not
saying they're they're terrible about
things they they're more talented teams
and NFL than the Buffalo Bills but this
team is going out there and they're
there play resembles the the thought
process the mindset of their head coach
Andy Reid in Philadelphia had the four
years or the three years in a row of not
making it to the Super Bowl yeah there
was a notion still with this Kansas City
Chiefs team that no matter how well they
do in the regular season the player so
the other thing that matters do you
think Andy doesn't worry about it do you
think that's his chip on his shoulder
how do you think Andy looks at the
playoffs and the pressure and how people
kind of go you're fine the regular
season but you haven't won the big one
yet
well that sits on him I'm absolutely
sure it is because Andy is like kingly
aware of his surroundings he's keenly
aware of people talking about him things
like that great I mean one of the best
coaches right and probably the best
coach that ever had and so he's always
his F star of how he's viewed by others
and I think that's fine I don't have a
problem with that I think he understands
that he has a special team we had a
special team too
we were say
in 2005 yeah we weren't thinking about
making it to the playoffs we were saying
where we gonna be seated at can we get a
home game and can we get to the Super
Bowl and win that's and when you look at
this Kansas City team
nobody has ever in the last two years
this year last year has ever said you
know what
I wonder if this team's gonna make the
playoffs nope the question is can you
get home field advantage can you win the
big game that's the question in Andy
Reid throughout his careers if they're
out his career has has always been faced
with that can you win the big game
that's the question Kay you man is a
clock when it's minutes two minutes left
and you got one timeout when are you
gonna call that time off can you manage
that yeah that's the question about Andy
Reid can you win a big game and can you
manage the clock how different is a
team's energy when when you know like
that year that you guys got teo and
you're like holy [ __ ] yeah look at our
defense and it was like the first year
the offense was like matching the
defense and I think about teams like the
Chiefs right now what is how different
is the energy in that building compared
to a year where you're a playoff team
compared to a year we're a Super Bowl
team the building is is it pressure is
it excitement I'll give you a sample so
there was you know we played 16 games so
we probably might that's super year we
probably the starters probably paid 13
games right like no and just played in
13 games yeah out of those 13 games
probably eight of them we played the
full game so I mean you're talking about
a half of season we were not even
playing either in either a full game or
half of the game tonight Dustin we were
beating people pretty bad and that that
just kind of permeates into the building
everyone's excited we're just decided
about it would be Sunday it would be the
off day and it'll be Sunday again
because you're just excited about
getting to that next day it's almost
like a kid the night before Christmas
you just want to get to the next time so
you can go out there and do it again it
was funny t OE and I tio and I used to
have competition who was score the most
I mean we know we were going to score it
was just how many touchdowns are you
gonna score we were all he would go back
that's one for me and I'll be on the
bitts like the only thing I'm thinking
about is I know they're not gonna stop
us how many can I get so that I can beat
tio as far as touchdown we were
especially like that when you watch this
Kansas City team I was watching a clip
of Hardman oh my goodness it
he's not the fastest guy in the league I
don't know where he bobbled it then ran
across the field for the first it was it
was phenomenal in I wrote down on my
notes I was like one I wrote down who
the [ __ ] is scouting wide receivers for
the Chiefs and then the two is how does
somebody that's this talented last to
the third round
doesn't make second I'm just telling all
the NFL teams out there focus on the SEC
wide receivers yeah because none of
those teams have quarterbacks and all
those kids are 5-star recruits and they
all run for threes and we haven't even
seen their potential yet because think
about Calvin Ridley Calvin really was a
first pick in the first round pick and
his statistic sucked because his
quarterbacks couldn't even throw it to
him but but Harvin but you were talk
about the clips and the Chiefs and the
energy of always you if you walked into
the building of the Chiefs right now
it's probably like Christmas in there
because they're just excited I mean
obviously they're excited about the
three-and-oh star that's great but
they're excited where they're at as a
team it's about building something that
you can see has some longevity first of
all you got a quarterback that's gonna
be there for the next 15 years that's
special so you know that already
second of all you have a head coach that
you know he can build their franchise he
can build something a character culture
in the building that's gonna be special
then you start adding more pieces
hardman and you bring back shady and you
got hills coming back at some point
you're gonna build an author I mean it's
just you start putting the pieces
together and how can you not see that
just somebody if you had a business you
said you know what we went out and got
the CEO from Google and we got the CEO
Oh from from from Microsoft we we got
all these good people and you have to
understand when we start putting things
together it's gonna make all big sense
it's gonna be really really nice that's
how special that that building must be
out there that's what I think is also
special about Andy is there's a lot of
teams this happens in sports when the
Warriors got to ramp there's only one
ball yes right when the Rockets got
Westbrook there's only one law the
Chiefs should be a team that we're going
you know is Travis Kelce and Tyree kill
or are they worried about getting the
ball and it's not even a story you know
why because the head coach says you know
what we're gonna win winnings number one
when he's number one you're gonna get
your stats I'm gonna get you off Travis
Kelce but almost
Tariq Hill his I'm gonna get this
running back Williams as well as McCoy
his paddies gonna get his - he's gonna
throw the ball deep everybody if you
just do your job
trust me I'll take care of you my other
question is it's kind of like a 300
thing number and 300 where he threw the
spear at the end and he didn't kill the
King but he showed that he was human
right by making him bleed when you're a
team like the Chiefs or your team in
2005 is there a time where like you you
suffer a loss or a games a little bit
closer and you realize wow this machine
while phenomenal can still be attacked
I'll never forget this mm money but 2004
we're undefeated at a time we're just
rolling through tain Steele's first year
we go to Pittsburgh and Pittsburgh has
always you know for a time they spurt
for some reason Jerome Bettis would
always play well big against the they
were in a nasty physical team the AFC
North at that time was just nasty and
physical there was no fear so we're just
gonna punch in the face well we weren't
we were a physical team but we weren't
nasty like David they were just like you
I would hate playing them in a preseason
because she'll we don't come out
everybody has tricep biceps arm they all
greased up and before the game you in a
pre this is a preseason you look at him
like man the last thing I feel like
doing is dealing with these guys for a
quarter or two quarters or whatever but
then we get to the game in the regular
season and it might have been 21 nothing
in the first quarter it was it got ugly
clears 21 a Steelers they were you guys
you were undefeated this is when Donovan
and teo got into it on the sideline damn
in Pittsburgh they started it started
there so you know after the game we were
like okay we need to we need to
recalibrate I mean what's the deal we
got pushing them out
we've never been pressing them off like
that before we kind of we understood
what was happening we understood how we
went down we made some mistakes but you
got to recalibrate after that the key to
those types of situations is having a
leader not only the head coach but in
the locker room that says hey this is
what happened calm down it's not a panic
time let's go back to work then listen
the cheese aren't gonna go 16 - no but
there's gonna be some game that they
ended up making some mistakes and they
get they end up losing and now it's the
important part for the coach when you're
coaching it's not about only monitoring
things when you're winning it's when
you're losing you got to come in there
and say hey man we're gonna go back to
work we're gonna work even harder this
week it will never let that that feeling
that you have right now that will never
happen to you again because when we go
to work today we're not gonna allow it
to happen so then for us as fans let's
say the Chiefs lose to the Lions on
Sunday okay
the big thing that we're then looking at
is how they come out the next week
that's right so for our new sounds back
so if we see a team come out and destroy
the next team you go this team is beyond
for real they handled it they figured
out what their weaknesses are but if
they come out the next week a little bit
slow
should we then look at it and go oh
they're having doubt now well here's a
question is it a blip on the radar oh
it's just just one of those things we
had a bad day everybody's slipping the
wrong bed everybody you know you had a
terrible week some guy - some people are
hurting some people sick or is it oh
well this guy's hurt that guy's hurt and
now this team that we thought were
juggernauts they're just average because
they can't do those things again and I
just think that Andy has built a system
out there especially with that
quarterback in there and they got a
bunch of guys their top receivers gone
there's not many teams when you lose
your top receiver their top receivers
gone they're starting left tackle and
they're starting running back there's
just not many teams that like that would
people almost every franchise except for
the Patriot look at the Eagles I'll just
give you a primer they lose their top or
two receivers they look like an
elementary school of roster as far as a
team offensively yes they can't get it
done their offense suffers and their
defense suffers Andy doesn't allow that
to happen because he has a bunch of guys
that just have failed in that next man
up deal and that really works out there
in Kansas City and it's it's so rare and
it's so [ __ ] special yeah
in 2006 you were six in the NFL and
yards for scrimmage
yeah with 1916 yards good season can you
name the five guys that were ahead of
you
hard for me to think that I was six I
thought I was like second or third I
probably LT LT was number two I couldn't
I couldn't name anyone other than that
who took give it to me Steven Jackson
Steven Jackson what monster year Steven
Jackson I'll tell you this about Steven
Jackson huge me he's a grown man grown
grown man so he's big
he's strong he has soft hands can catch
it out of the back feel so good already
he was quick and at some point during
the season and I we talked about it last
week
some point during the season if you're
playing against a team that knows are
not going to the playoffs they start
making business decisions against that
guy and then he destroys and he Stephen
Jackson is one of those guys where I
look at his career and he's like up
there and rushing yards all-time in
total yards yeah and I feel for them so
bad because he was on that Rams thing
that sucked for so long was their
quarterback Sam Bradford towards the
inferno and he had so many bad quarter
but I don't remember anybody else they
were just all bad just guys like the end
of Marc Bulger like it wasn't working
anymore the other guys in front of you
Larry Johnson you are you serious
but he was he went off that year in
Kansas City insane you have 2,000 yards
rushing I think he did yeah so you went
off that yeah that makes sense Tiki
Barber no way do you hear about you were
better than to Kiki barber who was
better at their prime you were Tiki I
was better than Tiki at my prime he is
his prime lasted longer yes he also
didn't have a fumbling breath yeah yeah
his prey his prime lasted longer I was
better at my prime my prime was just the
really cool thing was as Tiki was a
Eagle killer and you were a giant killer
Tiki was good down at Tiki could do a
lot of the same things a lot of I think
really Tiki I don't know where we'll go
back to like who was the running back
that really made pass catching like a
thing that but he's definitely up there
no Marshall Faulk was a guy yeah for
sure but Marshall he was soon after LT
Tiki did a lot of the same thing yeah
yeah and the other guy that was in front
of you Frank Gore Frankie G and Frank
Gore is still [ __ ] playing Frank
think about that that was 13 years ago
Stephen Jackson's been retired LaDainian
Tomlinson is in the Hall of Fame which
means he's been retired for five years
yeah and Frank Gore was one of those I
mean tell you something off Frank Gore
so I go to San Fran my last year and the
first day I meet him and I had never met
him before I was like Frank listen I'm
not here to replace you bro I'm just
here to kind of chill out a little bit
compliment any compliment you well
you're tired I'll go in it lets a play
where you're not getting the ball I'll
go in and so the first practice I'll
never forget it
Frank took every rep
took every wheel every play every rep
second practice every rep so the third
practice up with to the codes like go
hey man I kind of want to learn to
office and stuff like that but I can't
because I get no reps at practice that's
just how Frank is and I'm like all right
so first ten weeks of the season I might
have played six or seven plays
legitimately 60s ever played in ten
weeks right and so at this point I'd
take weeks I'm like alright well alright
see how the type of year this is gonna
be I miss I'm inspecting to go for the
rest sorry I'm not not that you just
chill but you like okay mentally you
slow down you slow down you don't you
know check artery out yeah but you're
closer to check it out right and so next
thing I know Frank gets hurt oh I'm like
oh no oh no because you got well Tim
weeks ago I was in shape and I was
slowly fading to retirement Frank Gore
effect and but to see Frankie G
hardest-working running back I've ever
seen in what way
I'll tell you this after a game your
body and he's not he's not tall you know
he may be an institute oddities but he
packing his head though he's thick he's
strong and he loves football a day after
the game I couldn't walk I can't walk
he's just your body's too sore legs
again Frank is running sprints he's
doing squats today after the game that's
why he's still playing he tastes cured
his body in a whole different way he
learned from Fred Taylor down there
Florida they they work hard other
machine from Fred tell us apiece
absolute B's should be in the Hall of
Fame certainly should be considered for
the part of Fame because he was a beast
speed and power and he was big you're
not surprised that Frank still going I'm
not I'm super surprised from this from
this element I know how age catches up I
also know that he had a couple knee
surgeries yeah and I know how they might
need affected me and so for him to be
able to still do it he was up there with
McCoy and McCoy like listen Frankie G is
a machine really he's called you he's
like what's up with Frank I'm like Frank
Frank is a machine like a straight
machine he's a beast and so I'm not
surprised at his success I'm surprised
at his body is still who is he does he
joke about it at all or is he just like
straight business now he has fun but but
but Frank is one of those guys that he's
emotional and so if you I remember we
yeah what do you mean we played an
Arizona one game in in before the game
he broke his down he was crying before
the game we go
got beat and he was crying at the game
like he was so most custom people out
like he Frank is one of these guys that
loves football and does not tolerate
losing a tall man in a fellas not not
feel feel with guys I love the game he
loves football Frank is one of these NFL
lifers type of people he has a young son
play I think in college at this point
because he's been playing for that long
Frank is a machine look he's crying just
because he wants that mustache in it he
wants to win only thing he wanted we
were open six oh of course he's crying
everybody was crying at that point but
he wants to win so much that he's
willing to do anything he he'll run
through the wall here one literally run
through a wall just for his team to win
you ever see him do something crazy or
like wow this guy's a lunatic he never
he wasn't doing thing crazy he just he
was just so consistently
all the time he was one of these guys
like loose he would in practice he was
saying no you got to take more reps he
telling a burner Danis take more reps
John's Morgan do more so that we can be
better I mean he's one of these guys
that's like go come with the rest of the
rest of teams like bro my body's wearing
down the rest it seems like yo I'm tired
let me get a great you're telling me
Frank Gore's been playing for what seems
like two decades and not only that he's
probably taken almost every snap and
practice down so the wear and tear on
his body is not just all those snaps in
the game no doubt about and that's great
you think about his style though again
just run right into just go run somebody
because back in the day San Francisco
they ran power run downhill and go run
over the linebacker do that 20 more
times this game man
that's how Frankie G plays so I've
always said that the argument against
Frank Gore for the Hall of Fame is
there's probably never a season where he
was like the number one running back in
the NFL yeah but I guess the argument
for him is we're likely never gonna see
a guy do this again I think that Frank
Gore makes a Hall of Fame I think that
the number four running backs and to get
into the Hall of Fame is 12,000 yards
Frank has 14,000 almost almost 15,000
yards how do you how do we discuss the
running backs like Emmitt and like Frank
where in terms of like the talent that
it takes the agility the speed we're
never gonna put them at the top but the
sheer length in which they've played is
so incredible how do we compare those
two LaDainian Tomlinson or
well Davis that was incredible for six
years in in Terrell was he wasn't him
incredible six years more like for him
but first couple years he wasn't that
guy yet so I think um I think when you
talk about the fall you first of all you
got to look at the numbers what did a
number say oh the numbers say for Frank
fifteen thousand yards then check yes
right is he a winner Frank hasn't won a
bunch of games in his career I've they
played in the Super Bowl but he hasn't
won he's not you don't look at Frank
Gore and say oh his teams were just
great because he was on a lot of bad San
Francisco right so that's kind of a
question mark there but when you look at
his career he has ability to catch a
ball out of the backfield he's out his
ability to run over anybody to me it's
he's a hall-of-famer not a first-ballot
type of guy because I think Fred Taylor
prized that he wasn't a first-ballot
type of guy and I think he's a
hall-of-famer to hasn't even got in I
think Frank is a hall-of-famer just
based on longevity and production to me
that des appease volumes Frank or
legendary eagle oh yeah and then he
actually left and went to Indiana he
didn't want to come there he was like no
I'm not coming here cuz I don't think he
like I think he ended up talking to
Shady I think that's what it was - but
I'm curious is I'm seeing the running
back position change in the NFL and you
were one of these dual-threat guys and I
don't think we're ever gonna see a Frank
Gore again and one just the way you
evaluate running backs when you're
watching a running back compared to an
average fan like myself what are you
seeing that most people aren't seeing
like what do you pay attention to what
do is it what does his hips do can he
move Kenny that's why I look when I was
single that's what I looked out of the
dance flowing them wrong that hips -
yeah what don't hips do that's number
one can you that needs to be a t-shirt
yeah what do what them hips twist them
hips - can he gets from point A to point
B laterally faster than someone else
start stop if you stop because to me if
I'm coming over to you and I stop and
you stop your feet you're beat I don't
get me because I philip lindsay has
amazing start stop start stop like there
were so many times against the Packers
where he was like stopped and then bang
and in the linebacker look like they
weren't moving
that's perfect Frank Gore wasn't a big
make you miss type of guy but Frank
would find an angle so he would shake a
little bit and then find that weak
shoulder and attack that run through you
can you do that one of the things that
I've been saying from mild Sanders the
Eagles running back is open field can
you make a man miss if you can't make a
man miss if you can't make the first man
miss in the NFL then you're gonna have a
problem and can't he he hasn't he hasn't
consistently don't scare you that
worries me because a lot of times that's
that that tells me about your natural
ability can you make a man miss it's
hard to learn how do you learn how to
shake and bake you don't learn that
that's something that that is either
have it or you don't you can get a
little bit better at it but if you can
make a man miss in a hole that's extra
yard you talk about yards after contact
if I make a man miss if I can get from
here to over here and here that guy
still over there then that's a bunch of
yards I can get so you think pretty
quickly you can look at somebody and go
they got it or they don't I think you
haven't pretty has anyone ever like
really proved you wrong like you you
went one way and they surprised you or
was there somebody on the other side
that people were saying they don't got
it and you're like no trust me I think
that when III use a guy that I was up
close to when I saw Nashawn McCoy his
route might his rookie he's 20 years old
but the way that he personal he picked
up the offense really really fast smart
kid so he understands football he gets
it here he understood the blocking
scheme but he also understood that I
can't go full-speed to that spot
especially behind the line of scrimmage
I got to pace myself and that change of
pace is gonna fool the defense LeSean
McCoy we talked about make guys miss
LeSean McCoy had a like a four or
five-year run where I would put him up
against Barry Sanders nobody could talk
in terms of his ability to just stop and
break somebody's chuckle and go in the
other direction
know the only running back in the NFL
that I think can do it right now is
Lamar Jackson Lamar Jackson yeah what he
[ __ ] did to that dude on the Chiefs
not NFL running back but what I saw him
do he he has a knee and he's not a small
guy he's a taller
slimmer guy that's why you don't want
him to keep running but he does make
people miss in a way that quarterbacks
just don't do he's a running quarterback
but he's when he has skills of her
running back
when he has a ball to me he gets into
the open field it's it's not like I'm a
Holmes or an hour running to the pylon
it's no it's like he's running but he
also might stop and then go in the other
direction yeah he had that skill I gave
you a little bit of a homework
assignment and I hope that's okay
but I've noticed that in the fantasy
community and also the football fan
community there's three running backs
right now that are frustrating a lot of
people yeah
James Connor of the Steelers Joe Mixon
of the Bengals and Chris Carson of the
Seahawks all were first or second-round
picks in most people's fantasy drafts
and all of them I think people are going
right now what's going on and Brian
Westbrook has just brought out what
looks to be a book from the the Gilded
Age this is this is from this might be
from be sick Emma my daughter's picture
here but she's a preschool you saw
that's adorable
all right so what is this this is a book
that I just I've had it for a long time
but I put in here people that can you
blow will dust pop up but it's like old
school book you see that has a little
you know the little shiny page it looks
like the Bible like it yeah yeah all
right so take me to what are you gonna
what's in the book I have something no
but I have I have a bunch of notebooks
at my house yes I love notebooks to when
I'm just thinking of stuff I'll just job
it down whatever notebook is near just
no order it's just I just jotted down in
things that I'm thinking of okay
and in this book in particular we're
talking about the running backs okay
that's what we're talking about in and
what's going on in their world all right
so who do you want to start off with
first let's go James Conner first I
think so too I think I did see one
statistic online that James Conner is
one of the worst in the NFL right now in
terms of yards after contact yeah he's
not breaking tackles I am a noob I am a
super fan and I turn to you mister
running back what is wrong with James
Conner right now well III think again
stats will always mislead you there's a
couple things going on with James Conner
and number one is when you have Antonio
Brown on your team that changes things
it changes our defenses play yeah it
changes how how deep our safety is so
let's say you have Antonia brown who's
gonna get get bigger like beat you deep
so the safety normally lines up at 10
yards or 12 yards he's lining up at 14
15 because the last thing that you want
to do as a safety is get beat deep over
your head so you're a little bit deeper
now let's just say you line up at 14
instead of 10 that's 4 yards so now
let's say I'm a running back I break
through the line of scrimmage nobody's
there but to safety normally if you're
at 10 yards you're gonna meet me at 6
right let's say you make the tackle at 6
6 yard game yeah right it's successful
in anybody's book good good run but if
you meet me and let's say you start at
14 and you don't meet me until I'm 8 now
that's 8 yards that's 8 to 10 yards and
if I can make you miss there I'm gone I
mean it changes the way that teams play
in when you're missing Antonia Brown on
that offense that's different you only
have juju it's different you can go
double-team juju yeah and they've done
some of that another thing I think I
think the age of the offensive line is
affecting them the offensive line
they're not super duper old but we're
talking about 27 30 in January 30 31 and
33 to me that's a little bit old
they'll be not that's getting that's
reaching the age where they're a little
bit older the other thing you say about
the Steelers people may say that Antonio
Brown was their biggest lost people may
say that levy on bells their biggest
loss you knew else they lost the soft
season their offensive line coach Mike
Munchak Mike Munchak is now in Denver
yeah and people would tell me all the
time
Mike Munchak the best offensive line
coach the NFL that's right are you
seeing a change in that I seen what I'm
saying is that and really on all the
running backs we're gonna talk about the
biggest thing and I don't know that
James Connor has lost skill cuz I don't
think that I don't think any of the
running backs had loss skill but for a
running back if you're getting
penetration in the backfield if the
offensive line is instead of getting
pushed that way they're getting pushed
this way yeah I don't care who it is
unless you're berry it's gonna be hard
to compete yeah because I just got the
ball I took one step and now I'm hitting
the back of my offensive lineman I have
nowhere to go what do you want me to do
and so there are so many times that
James Connor has not gotten you know
like a head of steam he can't get two
steps in defeat in the ground before
he's getting pushed back into the
backfield
yeah it's not okay and so the other part
is
the Pittsburgh Steelers back in the day
Jerome Bettis and deuce was there for a
little bit and Willie Willie Parker fast
Willie popularly Parker they were a
nasty physical grinded our football team
over time they stopped being that they
stopped being that type of team because
big bit in his development he's like man
I can just carry things yeah for myself
now I went back to last year since Week
nine James Connor hasn't had over 15
carries that's kind of crazy for for
someone that especially last year early
on you're like oh no we don't need let
me tell ya guess what was happening with
levy our bear was there he was in 2005
carries a game I will I said this all
that James Connor was really good but if
levy on was out there last year he would
have been a 2000 yard rusher yeah and I
do not believe that James Connor is even
close to the talent level on Bama
Le'Veon Bell was somebody that even when
there was penetration he'd still be
patient the hole and he'd use that
penetration to create a new running lean
I personally believe that James Connor
is an average running back I personally
believe that the offensive line there I
agree with you there is no threat deep
and there is like there's nobody to take
any pressure off James Connor and I
don't think James Connor is that good to
do it if he doesn't have that well
that's just my belief well I think he's
a little bit above average okay but when
that happens when you take all the
things around you to made you successful
I Antonio Brown
don't forget the quarterbacks gone - yes
so you take that away now that advant a
little bit above average it looks kind
of average yeah because everything's
focused on you do you think James Connor
is a very talented what's your read on
him I think that um I thought that he
was he showed some things at the
beginning of last year not that we
haven't seen I just thought that he
played really well at the beginning of
last he was catching the ball out of the
backfield he was making some people miss
and it's a lot easier to make someone
miss when you're five yards down the
field opposed to two yards in the
backfield what about Joe Mixon because
Joe Mixon is a guy that has always been
seen as incredibly talented he's
somebody that went later in the draft
because of off-the-field concerns but
every look they have offensive line
issues in Cincinnati too
yeah they're first-round pick this year
was Jonah Williams out of Alabama and he
didn't even play it's right but what
what do you see right now to Joe Mack
again I don't think I don't think that
the skill set of Joe Mixon who I think
is a talented player yeah I saw him play
last shot boxing while all I watched all
of his games last year I watched all of
his games this year edible run but
incredible runt catches the ball out of
the backfield he's versatile but similar
actually it's a similar situation what
did they lose well not only did they
lose someone they less lost one of the
best receivers in the game an AJ Green
mmm now defenses play you differently AJ
Green is out Cordy Glen is missed every
single game you know what and the reason
that I would buy a lot of stock in Joe
Mixon is AJ Green is coming back yeah
you would expect some of those offensive
lines to come back and also like James
Connor scares me because you don't know
if he has a skillset to do it but Joe
Mixon has played San Francisco and their
D line has been great yeah Buffalo whose
D line is great it's the and Seattle who
got Jadeveon Clowney that's right III
have a little bit more faith in Joe
Mixon that he's gonna bounce back the
one thing that you can say about the
Cincinnati offensive line and it's not
all one person's fault but it's just
true if you get no push it's impossible
so you're seeing no push from that often
don't push it all like no push it's
almost the same situation as from from
the Steelers there's no push it's guys
in that backfield it's you can say this
about the Steelers too there are times
for Joe Mixon what happens is the center
in a guard opposed to double-team the
guy in front of them and then they're
gonna one guy is gonna peel off and
block the linebacker right yeah there is
just too many times where the those
blocks the double-team are getting split
so the guy that they're opposed to be
blocking with two people he's making the
play the other times is that when you're
blocking the guy with two people and
you're supposed to peel off and block
the middle linebacker the middle
linebackers making the play cuz he's not
getting blocked so to me either don't
know your assignments or you're just not
doing your dog one job and so that's an
offensive line thing Joe Mixon when I
went out of his way to say hey man it's
my fault I got to play better which is
the right thing to do as a running back
truthfully I wash all of his runs and he
hasn't got a bunch six carries first
game 11 carries
tene carries so that's not a lot of
carries around it carries not a lot of
time but also passing with this new
offensive coordinator at a much higher
rate cup yes last year they got blown
out by San Fran so that's why you kind
of explain that but you have to kind of
get into rhythm yeah and I think they
have to figure it out
I don't know that offensively look I
remember their GM this offseason the the
Bengals fans went got very angry that
they brought back Bobby Hart at right
tackle huh and he went on a rant where
he is pretty much like guys there are
not great tackles out there no we have
to settle with Bobby Hart but I am
interested because I think the game
scripts have been bad for the Bengals
they've gotten down early at the same
point when AJ Green gets back it's a
different game okay
the last one it's really one issue with
Chris Carson yes three fumbles in three
games and this goes back to last year
the big fumbling issue I don't believe
you've ever had a fumbling issue know
what happens when there's a running back
like Chris Carson where there's just a
chronic fumbling issue so you got to
understand who Chris Carson is and if
really if you don't watch them he's
similar to lady on bail he wants to run
you over he wants to be physical he
wants to be nasty and that's that's how
Seattle just they kind of Bri running
backs like this we're gonna run the
football 30 times this game and you're
just gonna have to run a couple people
over that's just part of the game
Chris Carson he's actually done pretty
good running the football when he holds
onto the football but kind of running
backs perspective it's always a 5 points
of pressure right and it's kind of crazy
in this technical the top of the ball is
one okay so if I'm holding the ball if
I'm holding the ball right so at the top
of the ball that's one point in press ok
another one is your forearm right yeah
so your your actual for your actual form
right there the other one is your ribs
your ribs your ribs so the other the
other two are here so you have all of
the your fingers quicker so gripping the
ball your ribs the last one is your
elbow keep your elbow tough because when
you have your elbow tuck the ball comes
right here gosh now if your elbows every
time you ran it you eventually did it so
much that it became subconscious a habit
yeah build it in to where that still
stood in here as you're running if you
keep this elbow
up all those fast people coming from
behind you they have nowhere to hit the
ball from mm Chris Carson does his all
LeSean McCoy does it a lot too he swings
the ball way out here he's faster he can
make people miss so guys that can make
you miss as a defender you're worried
about getting juked out of your shorts
you're not worried about getting the
ball but when you have big guys like
this that want to run you over you're
not worried about them making a movie
you missing you're worried about getting
run over so you have an opportunity to
just go for the ball instead you're
seeing right now is it Carson's elbow
that's his elbows too wide and so the
guys from behind him are hitting the
ball out from behind so if you keep your
elbow tucked like this the guys from
behind you the only way they can get to
the ball is come outside your arm and
hit it right right but you got all this
other four points that are protecting it
but he's popping it out his elbow was
slightly too wide so guys were behind
him they've been taught you see him
punching the ball up like this harls
Tillman yeah they're punching the ball
out and he's literally 20 yards
downfield yeah they're all great Bloods
he'd the old guys from behind are
punching it out and he's fumbling the
football didn't listen he's getting 15
carries every single game he'll still
get 15 carries and the number one thing
we've all heard is if you fumble you
can't play anymore like I've always
thought there's no worse thing for a
running back than being known as someone
that fumbles yeah sure it's got to be
like that was there anyone that you
thought was really to the most important
thing in the NFL is a possession of the
ball because a team you could come back
from some mistakes you could come back
from penalties if you turn the ball over
it's almost a deficit you can't win that
way I'm sure that you've had guys on
your teams that turned it over and
everybody kind of looked at them and
they're like dead man walking well yeah
my forget again I learned a lot from the
veteran guys Deuce and Dorsey and B
Mitch and those guys buck halter and I
said it's simple you gotta be able to
block can't you figure out the blocking
schemes and block for number five who I
can do that if you just so you know
Shawn barber actually told me there's a
defensive guy linebacker yeah he said if
you turn the ball over he went the
reverse where I played him in college he
said if you turn the ball over you
fumble you will not play in the NFL
period the only thing that matters is
the ball and everybody wants it so you
got 11 guys on the
side of the ball that are coming out
that you but they really want the
football and if you turn the ball over
then you will not play the only reason
Chris Carson is playing still is because
Rashad penny is injured that's that's
the only reason you can't put it yeah
really talented but but you fumbled
every so you're helping us lose games
you know listen they lost their last
game by six points and I'm not saying
that his fumble was the reason but
didn't get turned into a touchdown if
you want to make an argument for it you
absolutely could say turnovers can
contribute to losses when he gets on the
field do you think the defensive players
are chirping them well the snap this is
what happens with drops and fumbles
they're contagious your fumble once and
the only thing you're thinking about is
I'm gonna fumble don't do that again
it's just like if you step up to the
free-throw line as a shooter as a very
bachelor player and if you're thinking
don't miss don't miss don't miss I
guarantee you're gonna miss yeah you're
thinking athletes are not meant to be
thinking in the middle of it athletes
are meant to just react yes just go do
it and now he's thinking about it and
now he can't go full-speed he cuz he's
gonna be thinking about don't fumble
then he leaves the field and everyone
goes what happened with that fumble and
then he goes home and the wife's like
it's okay it's okay that's right if you
fumble but I'm curious like he goes out
there and and he's playing the Saints or
the Saints sitting there fumble
defenders are saying I know you're gonna
give us a chance I know you're gonna
fumble it I need to be the next one and
now good run but you gonna fumble next
when you're not thinking about it now
you got to think about it cuz they're
all you hear is them doing their job
talking trash that's you know that was
the scary thing about miles Sanders
that's what everyone talked about twice
and Sunday yes but but it's I mean I
just think about all the movies we've
seen mm-hmm like the program whether
making them walk around football all day
and they're like you know they're trying
to knock it out in the middle it says
listen it is we had with somebody fumble
when I was in San Francisco maybe the
first couple games so Singletary walks
into the me and he said listen everybody
on offense so during practice you have
the offense team the defensive team all
the reserve guys on offense usually
stand behind the offensive side of the
ball some of the defensive guys stand
there too but sometime they're on the
sideline so
he said everybody on offense you're
gonna hold a football all practice long
and if if someone walks up behind you
punches it out during the practice then
you got to run like laps I mean my knife
here I'm like what are you talking about
you want me to hold a football
concentrate on holding the football all
practice long how I gotta listen to
anything how am I gonna pay attention to
what the heck is going on a practice
field so now coach is walking around
trying to poke the ball we had guys
running all over the place
guys running laps and everybody it's a
joke now if the practice became a joke
because just trying to [ __ ] with me yeah
did you try to kick the ball out so it
was yeah that's in the program is
something similar happened yeah yeah I
love you saw this shefter came down with
the report Rappaport backed it up that
it looks like Melvin Gordon could be
coming back sooner rather than later and
it's interesting because hecklers got a
flow right now
Justin Jackson his backup is when the
leaders in the NFL right now in yards
per carry and I'm sure Melvin Gordon's
like maybe the same working out like I
thought it was going to well I think
that when they said oh no no no I'll go
ahead and look for a trade I don't know
or oh by the way we're we're not
discussing this to the end of the season
he was like oh all of the leverage that
you had because they need you all the
leverage that Zeke had because they need
you yeah first of all his agent should
have told him like this listen Justin
Jackson when you were hurt last year
played well bald
Austin Eckler last year when you were
hurt bald played well and they both can
catch it and run it the same way that
you can what do you think Austin Eckler
and Justin Jackson or thinking right now
don't come back and mess my money up mmm
because they haven't neither one of them
we got paid yet no none of them are but
I'm sure they're not saying that but in
their mind they're thinking well how is
this gonna work we're splitting the pie
two ways just imagine just I do this at
my house with me and my wife was single
is you got half of the pie I got half
one more kid okay you got a third I got
a third another kid you got a quarter I
got a quote and I got five kids yeah I
mean that problem I got is five but I
got three kids there's five of us in the
house I got 20 I got most of my kids
they eat half of mine anyways I got
whatever the smallest pieces in what the
big deal is that chicken yes I know so
that's what these guys are thinking
they're saying well
how are we gonna I had a flow so it cuts
me down from 15 carries to 10 and that's
a big difference in the running back
situation so but I'm sure they all like
each other of course they'd like you to
at the same point yeah and I want you to
be successful but I want to be
successful too and Melvin Gordon comes
back in how do they handle that do they
all go out to a dinner I'm sure they're
still talk sure they don't talk but at
the same point he hasn't been in the
facility yeah so I'm just curious like
how does often heckler and Justin
Jackson how do they kind of break that
down with Melvin Gordon when he comes
back I don't know how they do it but
what if they just they just ignored him
like didn't even say what happened
they're like yeah that guy yeah right I
mean I don't know how it happens I think
that all within a group within the wide
receivers group with them they're you
you are literally sometimes the only
ones cheering company like I'm I want
you to be successful when my second year
we had the three headed monster me do
some Buchalter I wanted those guys to be
as successful as they could I wanted to
get mines too now but if when they had
success and I didn't I cheered them more
because there were times where I had
success and they did so they had to do
the same thing to me I think they
welcomed them in open arms but at the
end of the day I wonder I want to win -
meaning I want to get paid in order for
me to get paid yeah which none of them
are gonna get paid us Andy I mean in LA
yeah but I got to perform does it hurt
your heart that we can have guys like
Melvin Gordon and we can just write off
the running back position as anybody can
go back let me let me tell you let me
tell you something about Melvin Gordon
he is a really good running back really
good and we talked minds me of Steven
dog when Jack says he does he reminds me
of him big physical never knows down on
first never goes down he catches the
ball well out of the backfield their
office just isn't predicated on running
the football and they're always like
that now - the number one conversation
that I hear all the time on Twitter is
people go in the running back position
doesn't matter it's been devalued well
they changed it though in the guy that
the GM out in the charges he changed his
philosophy no no we don't want to have a
single guy get 25 carries we want to
have three guys that can do it so I know
that all of them all the guys are
healthy at the end of the season and
we're getting the best out of each guy
they've changed the thought process if
your son
grew up and was a very talented football
player he let him play in the game
because I don't know what your stance is
and he said in the coach camión said
we'd like to play yourself running back
and you're like yeah but he's been
playing receiver
what would you are we have we reached a
point where even you would try to get
your kids to not play the running back
position I don't know that we've reached
that point I would want my son whatever
if he if he plays which I'm still out on
that but we're out on it I'm I haven't
quite made up my mind I'm leaning
towards being out but I'm leaning more
but you know that this is a safe space
well I mean if you don't feel
comfortable with your kids playing
football no I'm not that big of a fool
no no no I'm at this place where if he
wants to play he has to be 13 14 okay
years old I want his body to be a little
bit more developed yeah I'm concerned
about my son and this is way off topic
getting hit at an earlier age a bad form
bad coaching yes he knows the [ __ ] just
imagine who's coaching these kids and I
props to all the coaches all the coaches
yes props to him however I had some
really good coaches in the NFL right
they were good they've coached their
entire life they did that was their job
right yeah this wasn't like some guy
that came in after work and said not all
the coaches have the the best interests
of the kids in mind I'll just leave it
there that concerns but if he did play
let's say let's say would you wanted to
be a wide receiver and I would have a
choice yeah I would want to be a robber
Siri you get you get hit less you get
paid more yeah it's a no-brainer
yeah and Dad was but I'm of course I
want him to play the best position he's
at but that he can be but if you can get
hit hit less and pay more right that's
that's a no-brainer no-brainer I know
it's just it's it's it's it sucks
because I love the running back position
you know why sucks because running backs
are important this is why it sucks
because you're talking about protecting
the quarterback yeah well get you a
running game oh you want to give the
ball to the important guy in the back
okay you will talk about a make sure
that your quarterback doesn't get hit by
the blitzing linebacker Oh have the line
back they're running back block him yeah
you mean the guy in the back that you
don't want to pay oh oh we would another
guy out on the route oh they had the run
do it oh you mean the guy in the back
that you don't want to pay you don't
value that yeah that's crazy that's
crazy talk
it's not a lot of teams as out here that
look at the Patriots last year when they
started winning you know they were
winning all season but towards the end
of the year they started running the
football before they got you know this
season they wanted to run the football
why sometimes things change you got to
be able to run the ball they spin high
draft picks on running backs there's
some good running backs why wouldn't you
want to paint the reason is because they
get hurt well maybe that's why you
should pay him more because it's a
dangerous position in this world the the
most dangerous jobs usually get paid the
most mmm why not pay to running back to
most any if he has a five-year career
pay him the most for five years because
he means that much to your team yeah I
had a holdout one year right holdout and
I was I came back after I held out and I
was just wasn't talking to me because I
didn't want to discuss the contract but
then one day I was just pissed off and I
was like you know what I'm going to talk
to the media today huh and I went in
there and I'm saying all this crazy
stuff I had made a speech or whatever
and I said you know at the end of the
day here's here's the bottom line
running backs may not be important
across the league but for this team I'm
important I may not fit in Dallas I may
not fit in Washington but in this team
I'm important that's why you should pay
me and there are so many running backs
other quality guys around the league and
I think Melvin Gordon is one of these
guys that can do a lot unfortunately
he's in the situation where he has got
two other guys gyah first of all changes
thought process he has two other guys
that that can do similar things combine
them together and they're close to his
level and he's been hurt a little bit so
he's in a bad situation but you got
quality guys that can't get paid with
they should get paid because now GM said
you know he doesn't matter and and it's
becoming like a public agreement you
know you made me mad today I'm glad yeah
you got a little riled up blue you know
Jim Valvano says if you if you get angry
and you cry and you laugh every day you
live the full day now I almost forget
love the fall down at the food do you
see this Jalen Ramsey situation we
talked to we talked about on Monday they
had the flu
apparently they asked Doug Marrone today
about it and he laughed before he
started talking yeah
you ever had a situation on a teen that
you've been on or there's been a guy
that's like faked an illness or it's
been so untenable that he wanted to
leave I mean obviously we had the whole
tio thing but we've never been in a
situation where guys just wanted to
leave but it's it's it's funny because
it's tough man I can't imagine what it's
like to go in the locker room everyone's
like hey man you're gonna get traded and
then you're not getting trained you
don't get traded and you're still really
really good you just you want you asked
them to let you go yeah just let me let
me get out of here I don't want to be
here and obviously you just cussed me
out on the sidelines you probably don't
want me to be here either so I was like
it's more of a Tom Coughlin's thing than
am her own thing I'll tell you this all
of them Kaufman's boss Ron's boss he
said that he wants him here so guess
what and he wants to pay them Oh shot
[ __ ] yeah yeah the owner the real boss
the owner said I like I'll make you the
highs I'll make you the high space so
now if I'm Randy I'm like I'm at least
considering it why wouldn't he but it's
funny because bro we've all worked at
companies or the I don't know not
everybody we've been in situations where
the head man in charge he likes you yeah
but you got to deal with the other
people that's right and I don't work
with the head person in charge every day
no I work with the other people yeah and
that's not always fun well in sports and
sports is simple if you pay me the way
that their time are paying Ramsay now
all the little talk from the other guys
a Coughlin I hear you yeah I hear what
you said at the same point if I'm Ramsay
hey listen mr. Khan I know that you got
a lot of money you know you're gonna pay
me but I'm pretty sure because I'm the
best cornerback in the NFL a lot of
owners are gonna pay on time one payment
if so so yeah I could get a check from
you mm-hmm but I'm telling you that I'm
so confident my ability
I don't need your check that's right I
can get a check somewhere else just have
someone say that you gonna have a check
but yeah I just that may be part of the
conversation we're the best in the
business
absolutely it's part of the conversation
she is the best in the business and it's
funny to me that he said you know what
I'm gonna have the flu this week just so
you know all week long I may have the
flu I think he came in right and he's
like yeah not only do I have the flu I
think my back is hurting a little bit
too yeah I we
I'm gonna work we call this whole time
we call to hold in everyone says it's a
holdout that's right when you don't come
in the facility well you could hold in
you could be in the facility and be like
you know what there's something about my
knee right now I never stopped going
great
oh and you know what my elbow doesn't
feel good right that's right
chew like I really hope something is in
team meetings and every time everyone's
laughing yes and he's just going
I always wonder because she's got
tissues all over his desk I did the same
thing so I understand it hold it no I
did a holdout so I was out but I always
wonder guys
Trent Williams for example yeah losing
millions of dollars of dollars why just
not just go and be there and just like
I'm not playing I'm hurt I remember
there was a couple guys on my team older
veteran at the beginning the training
camp every year pulled they're growing
every year it's like growing on my ankle
and they hurt and how do you how do you
how do you find that out someone has to
go in there and rub it out to figure it
out no the groin was hurt every first
three four days the hardest days of camp
I'm just taste something in there
something in there is I don't want to do
the conditioner chest and I don't want
to do the first three four days of camp
it's in there somewhere
yeah that's my hold in what I'm doing
yes so hey all the other guys out there
Jayla ramse apparently gets it something
is wrong with your groin hey I'm gonna
tell you this here's the thing not
everybody can do that right you gotta be
up there something wrong you're growing
well then we're gonna cut you well find
somebody with a group we just got
finished talking about a perfect example
with Melvin Gordon and I'm not saying it
listen Melvin Gordon is a good running
back but there's different levels to
that if you're the best you can make if
you're Zeke you can make a decision
you're making a financier decision but
if you got other guys behind you that
can replace you hey that's the way it
goes let's do some quick big games of
the weekend yeah but before we get to
the weekend Thursday Night Football
Eagles Packers my one friend I told him
that I thought the Eagles we're gonna
get shellacked and he said this is an
underdog Eagles team it's right where
they want them
is there any chance the Eagles on a
short week completely banged up I know
al Shawn's playing can go to Lambeau and
we've seen historically that teams with
good defenses on Thursday night's win a
lot of the time even though last week
Tampa Bay went into Carolina and won
that game but cam was just terrible is
there and there was a like an hour-long
lightning delay it was actually two
weeks ago but is there any chance the
Eagles can win this game in your minds
a lot of things have to go right a lot
almost everything has to go right for
you to go and beat this team out there
because the defense has improved for the
Packers in Aaron Rodgers he's upset that
the offense isn't clicking yet we're not
clicking which means he wants to throw
the ball more and he has he thrown the
ball to bunch this season so I think
that um everything will have to go right
for the Eagles I'm talking our Carson
has to play out of his mind
al Shawn has to be on a different level
obviously you can't have seven drops and
I think they got to find a way to get a
running game and that's tough against
this Green Bay do things it's just tough
to do that and so all the things and
when I look on the defense side of the
ball all the things that the Packers do
good all offensively usually not it
hasn't quite clicked this season are the
the Eagles wheat points secondary one
point you want to go deep oh yeah we
suck at that too we're not very good oh
oh you mean Aaron Rodgers is gonna have
four seconds to throw the ball in the
pocket oh yeah yeah he'll car be up
there's a there's a reason why one of
the big things I write in my notebook
before every season is what Prime
players for every team had an offseason
procedure or an injury yeah because this
is this is the time of the year where
people go but Fletcher Cox is not hurt
why isn't he playing great
well Fletcher Cox had offseason surgery
and he's not there right now sorry and
he did have a foot issue and so I don't
think we're gonna get Fletcher Cox real
Fletcher Cox into week seven or eight
like there was a question about whether
Fletcher Cox was gonna play in week one
and so I you never saw this probably
when the Eagles drafted Derek Barnett I
had an episode and I freaked out here's
you cuz I didn't like Tim you didn't
like da roca okay because I'm not always
a fan of drafting the guy with an
incredible amount of statistic
because just meant you played for a rope
we broke Reggie White sack record at
Tennessee right and so my theory was
always when people tell me why is this
guy good yeah and they tell me that he
broke Reggie White's sack record but I
never heard anybody say he's explosive
he's fast like when they when people
tell me oh this defensive end is great
he's a leader
mm-hmm I don't give a [ __ ] about
leadership that's right I don't need you
to be mummy no I worry about he's a
leader in your set can you bend the
corner and get to the quarterback yes
and I never heard that about Derek
Barnett yeah and I'm not seeing any pass
rush and now I know that you're going up
against Aaron Rodgers it just feels
scared I got a weird theory about that
and you're actually the first person
I've ever even mentioned this to the
easel between us this is those bats it's
between us
the Eagles last year fired their
defensive line coach okay Chris Wilson
yes he was a guy from he was at
Mississippi State where Fletcher was
their old school guy I've been around
the league for a long time him and
Michael Bennett just didn't see out I
think they may have got into a little
confrontation huh they fired him they
got a brand-new defensive line coach
Phillip Daniels who was their former
defensive lineman's on the Bears and I
don't know him at all
but I knew I remember playing them
against the rest Ken's good player that
defensive line looks different looks
like guys not getting it done obviously
we can we can we can look at the
Fletcher Cox injury I would say there's
a lot of reasons Fletcher Cox injury you
should first long know Michael Bennett a
bunch of different things but it looks
to me Jernigan this defensive line looks
terrible when they blitz you bring eight
people you can't get so the quarterback
you bring four people you can't get to
know and you add to that Ronald Darby's
hurt you answered that your second or
Sydney Jones a second-round pick a
couple years ago just looks average at
this point no pass rush plus average
secondary play Eagles you're going to
get hurt unless something happens that
Aaron Rodgers starts throwing the ball
to the other jerseys unless something
miraculous happens if Carson Wentz comes
out and scores 20 points in the first
quarter in every quarter past that yeah
it just doesn't look good for our team
I really didn't the only way the Eagles
have a chance on Thursday night is it
Carson is MVP two years ago Carson and
does wild [ __ ] this is not the defense
to do that well let's say let's say he
is though the problem wasn't Carson last
week and I think he had some throws he
should have back that he probably wants
back seven drops the problem was the
seven drops that's the problem the other
problem is I don't know that Doug
Peterson right now as a play caller is
calling a good-enough gown no but as
we've seen and I always say this Doug
needs to have a few games where he's
trying some [ __ ] out and it's not
working and then he goes oh let's get
back to basic did you like the the the
guy that became an internet meme about
saying I've got those kids
Aguila of him love him I just I just
watched it universally loved this guy
everybody in John Clark caught up with
them dogs I caught two rat in for a
touchdown rule my day this kid the guy I
mean not a kid is a guy he did you sorta
but he did catch two people which is
amazing which it when the fire is
blazing he didn't he didn't even have it
like a firefighter sooner one I just I
want to say one thing
he's everybody loves to [ __ ] on Philly
fans yeah because of all the things that
have happened in the past but we also
give the sports world people like this
and those people do not exist in a ton
of other cities Boston is a city where
it'll happen or Boston to of course with
the chronically bad people you also get
these amazing super fans right that give
you these great moments I mean you're
[ __ ] welcome the Philly fans haven't
done anything bad in a long time yeah I
love the fact that everyone goes this
was the horse last year we I don't know
they punched a horse put the heat eight
horse poop well one yeah that was a
different guy but one guy did punch a
police horse straight to jail just come
follow me sir but you're an asset if
you've ever had a horse kind of walk up
to you have a horse farm so yeah I have
I have you so you want to punch horses
now so I had this as a complete story
that is apropos of nothing when I was in
Louisville I work too much I have a
chronic issue where I work too much and
I would stay at the office until like
1:00 in the morning because I worked in
local TV and I was like I'm gonna
cut up all my stuff and put it online
and we had a janitor there and I'm not
gonna say his name but this janitor was
like lived in downtown Louisville and
like black guy with the most energetic
thing ever and he would just go outside
and rip cigarettes and one day he came
in and he showed me a picture that he
used to work at Churchill Downs and he
had a jheri curl
and I made fun of I said dude you look
like eazy-e like you see this this ice
this Ice Cube right here he looked like
that yeah and we would sit around and he
just tell me stories and he said I said
you ever get bit by a horse he said I'm
gonna tell you a story he said one time
I went into the stall and I would I had
carrots in my pocket and and this horse
came over and he bit me right and my
nipple and for and it he wouldn't let go
and my thing went black and blue and you
know what I did
I walked back in there one time and I
took a cigarette put in that
[ __ ] and I said you what dog
[ __ ] I said you can't do that he goes
[ __ ] AI did that [ __ ] never
bit me again racehorses too and I was
like that's not even your horse that
someone spending millions of dollars
he's like that's what you get for bitin
my [ __ ] ass and I was like and I
almost said his name and I was like bro
you can't be doing that [ __ ] horse up
they [ __ ] with me yeah and I was like
bro you were around horses for way too
it's way too comfortable yeah go around
me that's animal cruelty you can't do
that he goes that was that was my body
cruel type singing the horses bite some
people before though and [ __ ] them up
well listen that's one of the reasons
you don't should not you should not feed
horses with your hand because a lot of
horses they they're creatures they're
creatures are happy you come into the
thing with carrots in your pocket all
the time call for them and one just one
day you don't have carrots they're
biting that Pocky
they want their care it's not there
that's obviously a story my ever friend
Mike Columbo he's a cigarette in his eye
he's a news he's a news anchor out there
in st. Louis Missouri
and we laugh about him - cause we really
he was like both there and he's like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with ya the other
story we laugh about a lot is Danny
Trevathan who had a great sack against a
years great game but he also did the one
where he ran stopped and then car great
fake
I covered him at Kentucky and he had a
pick six one time and he's from the
South too
and I said man what did you see on that
play he goes I just saw that pigskin
spinning mm-hmm and I said did you
accidentally put an H and then he goes
what are you talking about I said you
said pigskin he goes it's a pigskin yeah
I [ __ ] love I loved editor 8th until
this day because he calls it a pigskin
that's that's how I want my defensive
players I don't want to I just want you
to go out there and hunt that's all I
want you to greet bills Patriots
I think the bills are gonna keep it
close I think they're gonna I don't I
don't know if they're gonna shock the
world shock the world but I think that
it's in Buffalo where Brady you know
he's had some great games he's also had
some really bad games Sam Adam say I'm a
Adams always comes back to my mind but I
want
I just think Sean McDermott knows his
Patriots offense Edelman's banged up a
little bit I I am I do not have the
balls to say the Patriots are gonna lose
this game because I think that defense
is gonna really [ __ ] up Josh yeah I'll
say this and it's kind of hard there's
really almost similar so the Patriots
played the Steelers Miami then the Jets
week schedule right the Bills played the
Jets the Giants in Cincinnati I know so
I went my first thought was well the
Bills have played a much harder schedule
they're more prepared for the game but
that's just not true no I believe this
I'll go out on the moon huh I'll take
Buffalo I'm taking the game out right
I'll take Buffalo Wow what's making you
feel this way there's not very much
that's making me feel this way
I just just you gotta hide you know yeah
you're feeling in your gut a little bit
like it's about time that they let's say
you take away Josh Gordon the bills run
game is okay so far I think Shaun
McDermott it probably I'm biased because
I know him and I like Shaun a lot
I think he's figured this thing out for
the Patriots and I think that they can
rattle Tom just a bit and I think they
have the defensive line allowed back a
core that can rattle them it's just a
bit that what's the line tell me the
line the line I think is it's either six
and a half or seven
I would definitely bet that I definitely
would I think they had the the defensive
wherewithal to be able to rattle on
just enough to make him make a mistake
what's not a lot of teams can do right
he can make one mistake and if Josh
Allen can just have a day so a lot of
different things have to go into beatin
the Patriots period look I'll talk I
talk about this game all the time
Patriots at Bills last year the final
score deceiving is hell 25 to 6 yeah the
starting quarterback for the Buffalo
Bills last year was Derrick Anderson who
at was not on a team four days before
the game but they had injuries to Josh
on had to come in in the third quarter
it was 9 to 6 New England it was 12 to 6
heading into the fourth the only reason
it became 25 to 6 was after a James Boyd
touchdown Devin McCourty had an 84 yard
interception return it is a tough place
to play Buffalo is 3 a know that fan
base is gonna be going nuts check this
out I'm just worried about Josh Allen
throwing some pick 6 over the last two
years Tom Brady has three only three
touchdowns in four games last two years
three touchdowns versus the bills he has
four interceptions again I'm listening
you know this I bet there's no other
team that he has those stats over the
last two years this may be the team that
can force him to a turnover this only
had one game so one game yet
week 16 he had two interceptions last
year 2017 he had interception at least
one interception in each game they
played four interceptions total in the
last two years I'm just telling you that
this may be the team that can force Tom
into some mistakes you know they could
do it and their office just has a day
yeah that's different I'm gonna talk to
Warren sharp about this so I'll let you
know before you put any money yes he's
our spiritual guide at the same point
I'm looking at the over-under at 44 and
I'm thinking a point put it under a lot
of points I was like I don't even I was
like you have a Patriots defense that is
at a historic pace yeah you have a Bills
defense that's insanely well who scored
all those points this to me is like 17
14 21 16 unless something crazy happens
89 yard return
all right and then the only other game I
had is
you have an undefeated Cowboys team
going to New Orleans Saints went into
Seattle in the rain come back in the
dome they did have in that game against
the Cowboys a fumble return for a
touchdown
it had a kick return for a touchdown
different and the thing is what the
Cowboys is what you brought up with the
bills are we sure they're really good
they've beaten and I believe they are
I'm just saying
they've beaten the Giants they've beaten
Washington discussion and they've beaten
Miami yes the Saints have outlasted the
Texans have gone they had to play the
Rams that's what juries and then went
into Seattle I think this one is gonna
be a knock-down drag-out now Cowboys did
go into New Orleans last year when New
Orleans was high and mighty in Medan and
I do think this look good and I will say
this I think the Cowboys defense will
this year be phenomenal I still think
they're getting over a lot of injuries
they did just get Robert Quinn back
their suspension but this game to me is
a coin-flip type of game I don't know I
think I think in my mind last week I had
the Saints losing right in Seattle cuz I
thought Seattle was just far and above
better especially with Teddy coming out
I thought they were better and I wonder
and I don't know this would be true I
just wonder here's a question I have
okay did they just win their Super Bowl
last week because Teddy and you go to
Seattle and we watch my gut my gut is as
anytime I see a team that gets one or
more scores based on special teams or
turnovers and it's an emotional game and
I just watched a clip of Teddy
Bridgewater in the lock from after the
game holding up a football and being
emotional yeah and that was our let's
prove that were more than jerseys game
and Dallas is coming off a game in which
they were up 10 to 6 at halftime over
the Miami Dolphins and probably got an
earful all week that if Devante Parker
actually or Preston Williams actually
catches that touch on the end zone
you're losing to the Dolphins at
halftime anytime I see a team win and a
team almost lose to the worst team of
football I go bet against that here's a
question for you and this is what I
think is gonna this is what I think is
gonna happen
we haven't seen Zeke do his thing quite
yet
just haven't seen them because they
haven't needed them they played three
bad teams I think this may be the game
where Zeke gets going a little bit the
question is can the orders defense stop
them hmm and what do they have to do to
stop Zeke not me that's the dilemma for
all teams I have the ability to run the
football especially with Amari Cooper on
the outside ball in like what do you
have to do to stop the running back well
if you got to put eight in the box then
this new improved dak Prescott now is
your time to shine the line right now
for that game Dallas has favored about
two and a half on the road on the road
which shows you that I think I think I
would pick Dallas in that game yeah
because of everything and we just talked
no I think that no no no do you mean
you'd think you picked out there there
there I would I would lay the points and
take Dallas yeah I would take down a
suit yeah of course I would - I think
they're the better team I still think
their quarterback play is gonna be
better I don't think that I thought
Teddy had a good game yes not great I
think that are offensive Alvin Kamara
beings how much Amira is absolutely
special and I look at Dallas and I go
late in very nourishing Jaylon Smith can
run side to sake in the move but we saw
it last year in that game in Dallas it
wasn't Dallas right now my make tell us
one of my super condos they they went in
there and they beat up Drew Brees
beat the [ __ ] out of them they beat him
up I think they still get to the
quarterback I still think that I mean
this is what I saw from the the Saints
last year Mark Ingram suspended camara
just had had his way he catching the
ball in the back there they throw in the
to him all the time he's running the
ball that's what they went back to last
week and he had a great game yeah I
don't know that you're doing that
against Dallas no and the other thing is
- is Michael Thomas I think amber told
me this before the show that camara and
Thomas and Amari and Zeke are the two
top running back wide receiver combos in
terms of yards but I look at the
matchups and I look at Marshawn
Lattimore who I do not believe I think
he is a very good cornerback but I think
Amari Cooper is a very tough matchup
because a lotta more likes to be
physical and Cooper's all about speed
and I look at this
the linebackers of the Saints and they
lost Alex ends Aloni a few weeks ago and
I don't think they have the guys to
really bang with Zeke but I think the
opposite matchup is great I look at the
linebackers of the Cowboys in Van der
ash and Jalen I think they got a saddle
on the sideline they could merely do a 2
vs. once right were they staying there
whichever way Camaro goes sake you got
him which not a lot of teams have that
and I look at Byron Jones Byron Jones
can bang with Michael Tong that's right
because you don't you're not worried
about Michael Thomas's speed not gonna
pass you Byron Jones for everyone that
doesn't know was a safety at UConn so
he's physical as [ __ ] and if you
remember he had like an 1111 broad jump
he's one of the freakiest athletes out
there and if you've ever played
basketball against somebody that's a lot
more athletic than you not fun you have
to go in the block and hope that you can
get like six or seven points that's what
Michael Thomas is gonna have to go the
problem with the Saints is if you take
away camara and you limit Michael Thomas
that pass rush is coming other than a
sand hill who else is open Ted Ginn
trake want like they don't got those
horses I I think this is looks really
good for the kind of other part for the
Cowboys is that Prescott has developed a
relationship with gallop he has develop
relationship with cob gallop is out he's
out but Makabe Smith Smith and he goes
fly fly so I mean hey and guess what we
saw Kenny Stills and will fuller fly
against the Saints Tyler Lockett put up
like I don't know Kenny feels number two
receivers in Houston that's what he's
looking and then also who's the other
game that I'm missing
I mean Cooper Cup ran through the whole
[ __ ] Saints defense Cooper Cup is
that one piece that the Rams were
missing last year right so tell us on
this same game listen to think about
this dak Prescott no interceptions yet
right no he has to he has to yeah you do
one in the last two games yeah
turnovers big plays this this this
changes the course for teams that we'd
like turnover his big plays can you get
a turnover to deck can you get a big
play somewhere deep inside a ball if you
can that can swing the game yeah I still
like Dallas but those are the things
that swing this game swings games that's
what happens to the Saints up there and
so yeah see
still owe me a money but we have money
just money a money
Kalyan Ramsey yeah that's not going to
Detroit anyway so that's that that would
be Terry slays banged up banged up
Westbrook you're the [ __ ] man I
brother umber again thank you all the
research Nick thank you for putting
Aaron Rogers back there I really
appreciate that Aaron Rodgers and a
mustache if you have not seen ditch the
playbook yet with Kuhn and William so
you could lay implore you to check it
out it's a lot of fun and of course
Friday we're gonna be making a money
with Warren Sharpe for Brian Westbrook
the rocket man nice I didn't tell you
the story about the rocket man I'll tell
you next time next time we'll hear the
story of the rocket man I am the le of
koe moon I don't want to the high pitch
why don't you [ __ ] later please
[Music]